c'est au cœur d'une sublime forêt
allongée que se trouve la grotte de la
roche Cottard une grotte ou
l'archéologue Jean-Claude Marquet s'est
aventuré pour la première fois en 1976
j'avance et je monte la marche la haute
marche près de 50 ans plus tard ces
travaux de recherche sont enfin reconnus
ces traces de doigts gravées dans la
pierre de tuffeau ont bien été réalisés
par Néandertal il y a plus de 57.000 ans
si pour l'oeil de néophyte ce n'est pas
flagrant pour Jean-Claude Marquet il y a
bien une intention artistique derrière
ces lignes gravées dans la paroi sans
être assez digitaux qui sont tous
parallèles les uns aux autres ils
partent de la base du triangle qui est
en haut là haut juste sous le plafond et
ils vont jusqu'au deux côtés égaux du
triangle isocèle ils vont jusqu'en bas
ce panneau il a été fait avec
application
il est
organisé structuré
et puis il a été fait d'une manière
intentionnelle et ce qui conforte
Jean-Claude Marquet dans l'idée d'une
intention artistique c'est la découverte
en même temps que les gravures de ce
silex à un mètre 80 sous terre parmi des
outils que l'homme donnaitandertal
aurait fabriqué il s'agit d'un masque
qui représenterait un félin il a placé à
l'intérieur de ce trou naturel un
fragment d'os de Rennes pour que ça
devienne une création artistique l'homme
de Néandertal ou la femme a modifié la
forme globale de cet objet en le
retouchant ici sur le bord pour lui
donner une forme légèrement arrondie la
grotte de la roche cotta est privée et
interdite au public l'archéologue compte
sur l'état pour qu'elle soit rapidement
mise en sécurité notamment pour la
protéger de la corrosion ainsi que de
possibles intrusions
et pour aller plus loin sur le sujet
l'invité du 19 20 et Frédéric demouche
responsable du musée de la préhistoire
du Grand précis ni bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous depuis notre bureau de tour
d'abord votre réaction à ce que l'on
vient de voir les gravures de la grotte
de langer sont les plus anciennes
d'Europe pour le spécialiste que vous
êtes j'imagine que c'était émouvant
alors oui c'est une très bonne nouvelle
alors je suis pas un spécialiste de
l'art pariétal moi je suis responsable
d'un musée de Préhistoire musée du Grand
Pressigny et à ce titre je suis plus du
côté de la médiation en phase avec le
public mon rôle c'est de faire
comprendre le patrimoine archéologique à
travers les collections du musée au plus
grand nombre au public tu retournes en
jours mais le public touristique qui
peut venir aussi au musée de presseur du
Grand présigné évidemment la nouvelle
annoncée par Jean-Claude Marquet et son
équipe sur ses tracés digitaux dans la
grotte de la roche Cottard c'est très
important pour nous parce que ça fait
écho aux collections que l'on présente
sur la roche cotarde d'ailleurs au Musée
de Préhistoire puisque dans la galerie
Renaissance qui est le démarrage de
notre présentation des collections
préhistoriques nous présentons les
ossements d'animaux que qui avait été
trouvés par Jean-Claude Marquet lors de
ses campagnes de fouilles ainsi que les
outils en silex donnaitandertal donc là
on a un complément avec le côté on va
dire symbolique moi je dirais pas
artistique parce que je suis pas un
spécialiste mais là
l'article est sorti
au doigt par l'homme de Néandertal ont
donc été authent
ifié après leur découverte pourquoi un
laps de temps aussi long selon vous
alors d'après d'après l'article de qui a
été publié par Jean-Claude Marquet et
son équipe c'est surtout parce que
lorsque vous avez des gravures ou des
tracés de doigts sur la paroi ça se date
pas directement il faut pouvoir dater le
contexte dans lequel se
travaille ou ses activités symboliques
ont été réalisées et pour le fait pour
se faire il faut analyser les objets qui
ont été trouvés dans le sol de la grotte
ça c'est la première étape ensuite il
faut être sûr que dans cette grotte
mille ans
la fermeture du Porge par des éboulis de
la grotte donc ils savent que cette
grotte là elle n'est plus accessible à
qui que ce soit depuis au moins 57000
ans donc 57000 ans c'est avant en
principe avant l'arrivée d'Homo sapiens
dans nos contrées donc ça pourrait
effectivement être le enfin c'est la
démonstration que Néandertal
peut nous permettre d'en savoir un peu
plus sur cette époque de Néandertal
ah oui oui sans nul doute la merde
toutes les découvertes permettent d'en
savoir un tout petit peu plus ensuite il
y a aussi le travail de des autres
chercheurs qui vont je pense se mettre à
analyser les le travail les conclusions
de Jean-Claude Marquet et de son équipe
et qui vont peut-être apporter la
contradiction mais là ils ont quand même
des datations assez fiables de la
fermeture du porche par des éboulis qui
montrent que l'entrée de la grotte était
interdite à toute personne après
l'arrivée de néandert après le départ de
Néandertal on peut dire quand on sait
que c'est gravure sont trois
fois obsciennes que celle de Lascaux
doit-on s'attendre ces prochaines
années du tourisme allongé pourquoi pas
un musée
alors ça je sais pas si ça peut
déboucher la suite on est que la grotte
est elle elle n'est pas accessible au
public les les tracés sur les parois
sont très fragiles quand même et la même
ils ont des ils ont des problèmes de
d'arrivée d'air extérieur qui peuvent
effriter les parois il faut à tout prix
déjà dans un premier temps conserver ces
traces ensuite on verra ce qui pourrait
être développé mais effectivement ça
serait plutôt une bonne idée d'essayer
de mettre en valeur ces tracer dans la
grotte à proximité de la grotte ou en
dehors préhistorique effectivement
exceptionnel merci beaucoup générique de
mouche d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce soir dans le 19 20